私
肇社長は
1年間
腹筋
ずう磨崖します
筋トレブームが ok しております今日ははず見せそうです
11復帰300回1年で10万回という企画をしたんですけども混ぜ
皆様に謝らなければいけないことがあります
愛知年間で
ずう満開
できませんでした知らせ集
[音楽]
サボりましたやはりますって言うが2ぐらいピザさ本作の事実なんですけどあのサボっ
たといいますか
やる時間がない時期がありましてその間のとりあえず1月中には中満開ちゃんとやり
ましたこれも本当に信じてください本当ですじゃないと動画だしてませんちょ現時点で
10万回が終わった状態なんですけどもうちょっと地学の最後ぐらいから8月と9月の
最初くらいが
ちょっと忙しくて寿司食わきちゃったよもう自粛があげちゃって ot 時間が
なくなってきんどリサーチがもなく東京行ったり来たりすると本当に腹筋地てる時間が
なくて本当に忙しくて出来ませんでした体力的にも一年中万歳無理だったんですけども
極力時300回はやってたらちょっとオーバーしちゃったんで
1年と1か月13カ月で一応腹筋です
見ながらは10万回達成することができましたあの
本当にきつかったです1日300回に慣れれば余裕なんですけど時間かかるんですよね
今まで何かお菓子禁止とかなみ禁止とかやらなければクリアするものばっかりだったん
ですけども今回も自分がやらないといけないんで時間が足らないと無理だったんでねえ
かもう緊急事態宣言のず指揮官だからねっ
しゃべりまくってて
一方バックボディだったんですけども育てば忙しくなってね移動とか仕事が増えたり
するとしても時間が確保できなくてちょっとだけ足りない部分が出てしまったのでそれ
を1月中に行っておりました
本当にそれはすいませんですね
ただ自分が増える時間にはもう限界なぐらい結構やったんであのさっそく見せていき
たいと思いますあのまずでそのように確認したんですけどもなんかボディビルダーと
勘違いしないで下さい各党がとかお菓子食べまくって酒も飲んでラーメンも1月の最初
めっちゃ食ってて筋トレしてる人だと考えられないような生活をした上での復帰んだと
思ってみてください
もちろん最後のほうはちょっと絞り
したけどねでは1年と2ヶ月クッキーこちらレイ
ございます
[音楽]
横から見てもそんな感じですもういいっすよああ大きいんですけど脂肪がのってて
ちょっとトリガー少ないなっていいくらいの感じでございますあーあーこの恋ですね
この額ですもうね本当の価格次第ですよね腹筋はこれはめちゃくちゃ良いですね大きく
なってるんですけども死亡行っちゃってるからちゃんとはいけない
という状態ですね
[音楽]
はれてるって言われてるつ痩せると夫化け負けるんですけど
幻聴だとこんなもんですねぇ
これが腹筋児300円た成果です
もうちょっとバキバキ鳴ると思ったんですけども
あれはもう食事制限してないと無理入っていう感じです
いやでも何度も本当に限られなければね写真とか普通と結構いい感じなんですけどもう
何点くってますから
1格上初週5でラーメン食ってますからねラーメンってこのターナーがすごいでしょ
すいませんちょっと期待にはそれだ
と思ったんですけどもまぁ普通に食事して復帰13件かやってるとまぁこんな感じに
なりよって感じです
自粛期間中金本当にヤバかった合う水化物止めてタンパでつだけとってたから貼っ競馬
けどむくみ気になっててファンの方からちょっと違うんじゃないかと
はじめはそんなにムキになっちゃえだという意見が多くて復帰以外のキッドケッ
控えにしてるんですよ今一つついてはいるんですけどそれでストイックすぎると
ちょっと
需要と合ってない気がしたんで細バット目指そうと思って今こんな感じになってますほ
問ひけどマッチョですね競技もそんな
ほどほどにあって腕もまあほどほどこんな感じで
フィニッシュでございまー
あのねぇほんと来なかったわー腹筋自体ももちろん辛いですけどば慣れていくもんなん
ですよ
筋トレはねぇ決まった時間時間が決まっている人じゃないとね続けられないですねだ
から俺自粛期間とかさあもずっと家にいたからめっちゃ金土日てきたんですけどやっぱ
仕事で東急たいんだが深夜に移動したり朝から仕事だった気で生活リズムが
めちゃくちゃになるとちょっと俺はもう無理でした
一つ分かりましたねというのがまず一つ思ったことですねあと
食事で大勢の頃お腹優しいパシパシ撮ってたんですけどもなんかう刺激が終わってから
ほんとしんどくても釣りもなくなってて取るのすら面倒くさいもうほんと
市立山ねハようにみたいな9でやって取るのをやめたんですけど
だからオーダー作品が俺しかわかってないんですけども300ちゃんとやってるのにお
菓子食べバグったりなんか脂っこいも食いまくった後にお腹簿ように
あるんですよでも色々調べたり道とかな聞いたらやっぱり腹筋割るというのは筋トレ
だけでは無理で植生
どんだけ音中川理事会でもここに脂肪が誤用で乗ってる問われないらしいんでだこれ
これだかすごい筋肉ついてですよ
もう見えません巨大な腹筋がこれが10万回のせいかなんですけどもこれはもっと
見せるためには食生活から来
をつけなきゃいけないしっかりと皮だけの腹にしたらもバキバキバキってなってたぽい
です
まあコンベ食生活動向とは何を言ってないんでまぁこれで正解なんですけど
だからもうボディビルダーとかさ金とやってる人ほんと一色になって思った1年でした
さあ
もうちょっとはれてくれば超かっこいいのかというわけでちょっと一年間どういう
筋トレ知ったかメニューを見ていきましょう
どうぞはい8ヶ月ですこれ忙しいときはコレは300やる非凡多かったです
あの事例にしっかりヘナ顔つきより地面に着かず
上げすぎず絶妙に
あのクイクイってぜひ目のとかで来いってやってるのが一番スカ額が足りそうでした
これ120回ぐらいいセットでやってますして味投げですあの脚投げは下腹に行く
らしいのでこれで下腹につけてました
後輩によく手伝ってもらってました50回で1セットぐらいでした
そして足だけランダム右か左か前か後輩が勝手にやるやつ
ですこれ横腹にも効くのですごい全体的に鍛えられますね
あの結構きついし同じ場所を10回からやらぬ入れると後輩を殴りたくなってきます
ついて足上げエクストリームですしっかりと背中まで上げる奴ですもう足をぐっという
まで上げることを言ってかなりヒトマルに聴いてた気がしますそれでくびれが欲しい
この横のここにくびれ
できるらしいですよこれに10回くらいいるときついついよ
そして足パパですこれ1回2回で1回のファンとでしたね
これもうね50回ぐらいやるともう本当に腹に来ますしっかりねそう見てやってました
そしてたちアブローラーですこれたんでできるまでで結構に3ヶ月くらいかかったん
ですけどもこれが
ござい人でした皆さんもぜひやってみてください
pane
おっなんか間に合わないなあと思った時1日6回やろうかなと思ったけどそんな時間は
なくてもう諦めて
って1か月ちゃんととりあえず10番解散太郎と思って終わりましたすいません
あのサボってたわけじゃなかったんですけどもできなかったのは僕の責任です本当に
申し訳ないです
ただ1日300回腹筋自分がやって気付いたことは
関わりたいだけはキンドルだけじゃだめです食生活
ぷろたんさんも言ってました食事でなり取るかが髪はに台詞って言ってました
ん
やった氷見皆さん
いい結果ですか脂肪の下には執権で見えてるんでまあいいでしょ
筋肉つけたい人は kindle も大事ですけど植生からが大事です
みてくださいに撮ってよねー
あっは
[音楽]
bl